I carefully I'm being watched because I
don't like being watched and I have a
right not to be launched to me 125
billion cell phone conversations a month
that are being recorded constitutes
egregious behavior on the part of
government I like my privacy I like to
know that I I'm not being watched and if
the idea that you have nothing to fear
if you have nothing to hide requires an
ignorance of history because the history
in the United States unfortunately
demonstrates that people who have done
nothing wrong have a great deal to fear
from government power run amok guy I am
very disappointed in this administration
and shocked that they expanded the
surveillance state I don't think that's
what people who voted for the president
voted for I think the attack obviously
on our civil liberties and privacy but
also on the Free Press the attack on
journalists who are just trying to let
people know what people up there on
Capitol Hill don't want them to know is
really shameful it's definitely
upsetting that it's continuing I don't
think this is something that the Obama
administration originated although I
think that you know this is just a slow
bill to slow switch of the mission
mission creep I guess of the NSA and so
I have to defend Americans by taking
away their freedom this will in the end
sometime make them more free less
freedoms makes you more free personally
don't have anything to hide but I'm not
out here out of my individual interest
I'm here out of a civic responsibility a
recognition that my country cannot
survive as a land of the free if we are
all being watched constantly by a
government and at that a secret
government agency essentially embezzling
secret amounts of public funds to
conduct secret programs pursuant to
secret interpretations of laws with
secret successes and secret abuses I was
afraid that this structure the police
state the surveillance state the
national security state has
I'm bigger than any one party and it has
it doesn't matter if you have something
to hide or nothing to hide the
government has to engage in a process
before it seizes your personal
information and so it's wrong and people
really don't understand how where you
drive your GPS location here email your
telephone calls can tell a very detailed
picture of your most intimate
relationships we've got to be concerned
when the government has so much power
over our most private information you
ask us what do we have to hide what do
they have to hide if there is a court
that's actually monitoring it well then
why can't why aren't records ever being
released this administration has has not
been faithful to the pledge to protect
the Constitution it has instead taken
steps that would erode our First
Amendment rights our Fourth Amendment
rights our Fifth Amendment rights our
14th Amendment rights and other
constitutional principles